hey guys crack knuckles here with string
theory calm and today we're talking
about skeletal muscle hyperplasia so
what is hyperplasia and why does it
matter okay so there are basically two
ways that your muscles can get bigger
there's hypertrophy which is the muscle
fibers themselves getting larger and
there's hyperplasia which is getting new
muscle fibers and so just know from the
outset that hyperplasia is still
somewhat contentious topic about whether
or not it occurs in humans consensus
seems to be moving in the direction that
it does occur in humans to a significant
degree but there are still some people
who don't believe it occurs in humans
and there really isn't any debate about
the fact that hypertrophy is the primary
way muscles get bigger but there is
there is in my opinion compelling
evidence that hyperplasia does occur in
humans to a relevant degree and so
basically this video goes through the
evidence supporting that view and then
at the end I'll discuss how relevant
that is to your training okay so first
things first the majority of the studies
to this point done on skeletal muscle
hyperplasia have used what's called the
avian stretch model so that involves
birds and how these studies are set up
is they hang a weight from the bird's
wing and that stretches the muscle on
the muscles on the backside of the wing
and under that consistent stretch for a
couple weeks a couple months the muscles
get way way way bigger so if memory
serves the largest degree of muscle
growth ever seen in a scientific study
was you utilizing this avian stretch
model it was by Jose Antonio the current
head of the International Society of
sports nutrition during his grad school
days that memory serves and
it's all just absolutely absurd degrees
of muscle growth something like 90%
enlargement over pre-stretch values and
that included again something like 35 to
40 percent of that was accounted for by
hyperplasia getting more muscle fibers
and so it's not there's not really a
question about whether hyperplasia can
occur it's just a question of whether it
occurs in humans because it's pretty
undeniable in the avian stretch models
that hyperplasia did occur to a very
very great degree but again that
research isn't super relevant to humans
or normal training purposes because
you're probably not going to be putting
a muscle on stretch for weeks at a time
as an aside I kind of want someone to do
this they used something like ten to
twenty percent of the bird's body weight
for the weights they were hanging off of
the wings for most of these studies what
I would really like someone to do is
just get like 20 pound wrist weights and
hang them from your wrists and just
leave them on for a month or two and
just see if your traps get enormous
people would probably give you funny
looks but if you wind up with ginormous
traps at the end of it I figure it's
worth it so if someone wants to try that
let me know and keep me posted okay
anyway getting back to our normally
scheduled program
so moving on to other animal research
hyperplasia has also been observed in
both mice and cats using protocols that
are much more relevant to our purposes
here so basically they would bring them
up to apparatuses that would mimic
weight training type movements and have
them do pretty normal type protocol so
the type of stuff that you or I would
probably be doing in the gym and they
observed both muscle hypertrophy and
hyperplasia and those studies as well
not to nearly the same degree as the
avian stretch model but also to a
significant degree so there's very very
robust direct
evidence in animal models that
hyperplasia can occur
moving on to humans though all of the
evidence we have thus far and probably
will ever have is indirect evidence and
there's a good reason for that
two good reasons for that actually one
is that you either have to kill your
subjects or cut a muscle entirely off of
their body to to examine hyperplasia
there's there's not any type of like
scanner that you can put up to a muscle
that's going to measure how many fibers
are in it so the way the way you have to
account for hyperplasia is basically
taking a muscle completely off cutting
it in half and just counting the muscle
fibers so ethics boards are pretty
uneasy with killing human subjects for
the purposes of research you know
Nuremberg code stuff like that and also
it would just be absurdly tedious to do
this type of research on humans because
you have to count each individual muscle
fiber manually so in say like a rat's
muscle or a cat's muscle they have
they're smaller than us they have much
smaller muscles than we do so it's a
large task to count every fiber in the
muscle of a mouse or a cat but it's not
nearly as tedious as counting every
fiber in the muscle of a human so just
as kind of a point of reference the
human biceps have something like half a
million muscle fibers so I don't think
you're going to find too many people who
would volunteer to count half a million
muscle fibers in one muscle let alone
you know you're going to have multiple
subjects so counting to half a million
yeah 40 50 60 times you you're not
that's just simply unfeasible
so it's unethical and it's pretty much
outside the bounds of what you're going
to be able to get someone to do to
directly verify muscle hyperplasia in
humans so the best thing we have is
indirect evidence and it comes from two
two primary sources one is in comparing
muscle fiber size to whole muscle size
in bodybuilders versus untrained or
recreationally trained controls and so
basically if if a bodybuilder has 40%
more cross-sectional area in an entire
muscle you would expect them to have
roughly 40% more cross-sectional area in
each muscle fiber because muscle fibers
take up the vast majority of space in
the muscle you know there's some blood
vessels there's some nerves there's some
connective tissue but a muscle is mostly
just muscle fibers so but what they
found not in every study but in a lot of
them is there's a discrepancy between
how large the bodybuilders muscles were
relative to controls and how large each
individual fiber was relative to
controls so just just using some random
numbers if the bodybuilders muscles were
40 percent larger each muscle fiber may
only be 20 30 percent larger which you
could you could draw two conclusions
from that one or both conclusions one
would be that they just simply started
with more muscle fibers than the
controls did which you know that that
kind of makes sense on the surface
because they're getting super jacked so
it's not it's not out of the question to
assume that they just had more muscle
fibers to begin with or number two that
through training hyperplasia occurred
and they gained more muscle fibers and
so again this is indirect evidence
because with those types of study
designs you can't establish which one it
was or to what degree those two things
were taking place but better indirect
evidence comes from looking at
contralateral limbs of cadavers so in
one study right-handed people their left
tibialis anterior which is
is the muscle on the front of your shin
so sitting right next to your tibia in
front so tibialis anterior right-handed
people their left tibialis anterior had
about 11% more muscle fibers than their
right to be house interior did and the
conclusion that the authors of that
study drew was that just from the
frequent low-level demands of just
standing up walking around etc over the
course of a lifetime those repeated
asymmetrical demands just just basically
caused hyperplasia in the left to the
outs anterior because with that
consistent of a pattern there's really
no reason to assume that those righties
were all just just all happened to be
born with more muscle fibers and they're
left to be honest interior so that was
probably just a result of you know being
a right-handed asymmetrical person so
there's direct evidence in animal models
including cats and mice that we're doing
training protocols pretty similar to
what you might be doing in the gym and
there is indirect evidence in humans
some of it is weak-looking
comparing bodybuilders muscle fibers to
untrained or moderately trained controls
and also stronger indirect evidence
comparing muscles on different sides of
the body okay so the next question is
how this happens there are two main
theories one is that the satellite cells
around your muscle fibers can actually
just fuse together and form new muscle
fibers themselves
I believe there's in vitro research
indicating that that can happen and it
makes sense that it could happen because
those satellite cells are what become
the Myo nuclei that oversee the ongoings
inside the muscle fibers anyway so they
have they have the potential to do that
and the other one which there's much
more robust evidence for is fiber
splitting so you know you have a muscle
fiber that's just running straight up
and down and when it gets damaged
and those satellite cells come in to
repair it sometimes that doesn't happen
perfectly and it doesn't fuse all
together and maintain just one fiber
running straight the fiber will split so
it'll be coming this way and then branch
off in two different directions and
there's really really good evidence for
fiber splitting it's seen in a lot of
studies on almost every highly strength
trained cohort well I wouldn't say
almost every but a lot of them it's it's
not an uncommon finding at all
so so those are the two main ways that
hyperplasia could occur and there's
really good evidence that fiber
splitting does occur in a lot of people
okay so the last question is how
relevant is this to us how much is this
going to affect how we actually train
and the answer is probably not all that
much it's hard to establish just how
much skeletal muscle hyperplasia
accounts for total muscle growth in
humans so we know that just the
asymmetrical demands low-level
day-to-day life type demands can lead to
there being 11 percent more muscle
fibers in one to be a less anterior than
the other but you can't necessarily
generalize that to strength training so
it could be that because those demands
are so frequent that that 11 percent
hyperplasia would be way more than you'd
expect to see in strength training or it
could be because the magnitude of the
stressor from strength training is a lot
well it's just much higher magnitude of
stressor so if most of those new fibers
are coming from something like fiber
splitting you may expect it to actually
play a bigger role in strength training
and the fact is we just don't know how
big of a role it plays but from what we
can tell thus far it seems like you
don't really actually have to go out of
your way to try to cause hyperplasia to
make it happen so like I said with those
my studies and with those rats studies
they saw hyperplasia doing again just
basically like normal type training not
doing anything crazy like the avian
stretch model and like I said in a lot
of strength trained cohorts they see
split fibers without people necessarily
going out of their way to calls
hyperplasia so really there's not too
much you can do with this information it
shouldn't necessarily change the way you
train in any meaningful way but since
this is string theory this is a channel
about how you get big and strong so you
know knowing how your body actually goes
about getting big and strong
understanding the nuts and bolts of it a
bit better is never a bad thing so like
I said not necessarily a prescriptive
video just general information so uh you
know hopefully hopefully you don't feel
like you wasted your time hopefully you
feel like you're just a little bit
smarter for having watched this a lot of
resources will be linked in the
description if you want to read about
this in more detail and so if you like
the video please like the video and
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you in the next video alright bye